So
I'm excited
Yeah
So
Trifocals
Hello, hello.
Thank you for being with us today.
I want to extend a special welcome to anyone who is new or just here for the first time in a long time.
I'm so glad that you've chosen to be with us today.
Tonight, immediately following services, we will gather in the Family Life Center for a potluck meal.
Even if you didn't bring something, we'd love to have you join us.
We brought extra for everyone.
To get to the Family Life Center, you simply head down the hallway where the children's and the kids' ministry rooms are,
and then you proceed out the back door and across the breezeway area and then to the back of the property.
Next Sunday, February the 9th, we are having our service at 4 p.m. to allow folks to get to their Super Bowl parties.
Again, services one week from today will begin at 4 p.m. and be done a little before 5 p.m.
Our next State of the Table church business meeting will be February the 16th before service.
We will start that meeting at 4 p.m. and finish up before our normal service at 5 p.m.
That time is basically our church family business meeting where we cover things like leadership, transitions, budgets for the next year.
These candles are a sign of the presence of Christ among us, which is fully divine and fully human.
And now we will call to worship, and we will exit the kingdom of noise, hurry, and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence, stillness, and grace.
Now we enter sacred space, a space for prayer, worship, and adoration, a space to encounter Christ, revelation of God, heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to find you, to mend your heart, and we all come home.
You guys stand with us.
I know there's gonna be some brighter days. I swear that love will find you in your pain.
I feel it in me like the bleeding of life in my veins. I know there's gonna be some brighter days.
I know there's gonna be some brighter days. Oh, ashes fall from burning dreams. Oh, never live through times like these.
Oh, if you're trying hard to breathe in the dark, in the dark. I know there's gonna be some brighter days.
I swear that love will find you in your pain. I feel it in me like the bleeding of life in my veins. I know there's gonna be some brighter days.
I know there's gonna be some brighter days. Oh, if your screams don't make a sound. Oh, if your walls are crashing down.
Oh, if your heart just cries too loud all the time, all the time. Oh, I know there's gonna be some brighter days. I swear that love will find you in your pain.
I feel it in me like the bleeding of life in my veins. I know there's gonna be some brighter days. I know there's gonna be some brighter days.
I know there's gonna be some brighter days.
I swear that love will find you when you're in pain.
I feel it in me like the beating of my heart in my veins.
I know there's gonna be some brighter days.
I swear that love will find you when you're in pain.
I feel it in me like the beating of my heart in my veins.
I know there's gonna be some brighter days.
And we're going to transition into the prayers of the people now.
So if you guys would just follow along on your screens and read the parts that are in red aloud with us.
For this city of Sachse, Texas and for every city and community and all who live in them, we pray to you.
For the good earth you have given us and the wisdom and the will to conserve it, we pray to you.
For the old and the sick, for the widow and orphan, for the injured and suffering, we pray to you.
For the poor and the oppressed, the unemployed and destitute, for prisoners and captives and all who remember and care for them, we pray to you.
For the vulnerable, the marginalized, and those unjustly targeted for their gender, sexuality, race, or other perceived difference, we pray to you.
For those experiencing loss, loneliness, and disconnection, and for those struggling with mental and emotional health, we pray to you.
Lord, we know that you love us and that you hear us, so we lift these names and situations up to you.
For the names and the moments that we have spoken aloud and for those that we have kept in our hearts, we pray to you that they may have life and light, healing and hope, peace and a deep sense of your presence. Amen.
I wanted to read to us tonight one of the things that I love about the Psalms is just the honesty that David shares.
When things are going wrong, he's not afraid to cry out to God. He's not afraid to get angry. He's not afraid to say when he's hurting or when he's upset.
Throughout the Psalms, you can see both his lament and his victories, his sadness and his rejoicing.
I feel like right now in our society, what's going on in our communities, there's a lot to be sad about.
Caleb and I were talking earlier, and for the trans community, I know there's a lot to be sad about right now. There's a lot of fear.
I know for a lot of us, there are things going on in our families, in our marriages, or in our friendships that have been difficult and painful.
I know there's a lot of health struggles.
Even as we gather tonight, several of us were texting like, oh, I've kind of been fighting something. Yeah, me too. It's everywhere you turn right now.
And I just want to name that there's space for us to come before God honestly and say, where are you? What's going on?
Because David did it, and we can do that.
And then there are times where we can say, I know that he does not forsake his children.
I know that the children of God will not go hungry begging bread.
I know that he has heard my cry.
So tonight, I just wanted to read two quick passages to us as we go into this worship set, and hopefully make space and room for us to bring that honesty and that hope, that belief that he is here and he's hearing us.
How long will the wicked, oh Lord, how long will the wicked be jubilant?
They pour out their arrogant words.
All the evildoers are full of boasting.
They crush your people, oh Lord.
They oppress your inheritance.
They slay the widow and the alien.
They murder the fatherless.
They say the Lord does not see.
The God of Jacob pays no heed.
But I will extol the Lord at all times.
His praise will always be on my lips.
My soul will boast in the Lord.
Let the afflicted hear and rejoice.
Glorify him with me.
Let us exalt his name together.
For I sought him, and he answered me.
He delivered me from all my fears.
Those who look to him are radiant, and their faces are never covered with shame.
So God, we gather tonight and we worship not because our circumstances are good, but because you are good.
Not because we are not afraid, but because you give us strength to continue.
You give us hope to keep moving forward, God.
Thank you for the space to do that tonight.
You see me on the mountaintop.
You see me in the valley, Lord.
There is no home without you here.
And I find you in the crowded thoughts.
You quiet all the question marks.
There is no space your love won't fill.
You trade all of my fear for peace of mind.
And all my heaviness for dirt and light.
This will be my song.
You are always good.
I sing it all day long.
When the day is through, I am left with you.
You are always good.
And I set my eyes on perfect faith.
You'll finish what you started with.
My heart will be an offering.
You traded all my fear for peace of mind.
You took heaviness, my dirt and light.
This will be my song.
You are always good.
I sing it all day long.
When the day is through, I am left with you.
You are always good.
Melody.
You're singing back to me.
You're singing back.
Melody.
You're singing back to me.
You're singing back.
You traded all my fear for peace of mind.
You took heaviness, my dirt and light.
This will be my song.
You are always good.
I sing it all day long.
When the day is through, I am left with you.
You are always good.
You unravel me with a melody.
You surround me with a song.
Of deliverance from my enemy.
Till all my fears are gone.
And I'm no longer a slave to fear.
No, I am a child of God.
I'm no longer a slave to fear.
From my mother's womb, you have chosen me.
Your love has called my name.
And I've been born again into your family.
Your blood flows through my veins.
And I'm no longer a slave to fear.
No, I am a child of God.
I'm no longer a slave to fear.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You split the sea so I could walk right through it.
My fears are drowned in perfect love, yeah, yeah.
You rescued me so I could stand and sing.
I am a child of God.
Sing it out, you split the sea.
You split the sea so I could walk right through it.
My fears are drowned in perfect love, yeah.
You rescued me so I could stand and sing.
I am a child of God.
Oh, I am a child of God.
And I'm no longer a slave to fear.
No, I am a child of God.
I'm no longer a slave to fear.
I am a child of God.
Scott, thank you that you are a good God who takes care of your children.
Thank you that you tell us to come before you with confidence.
To approach your throne with boldness.
That you say blessed are those who are hurting, blessed are the meek.
God, would you continue to provide and see us through times that are troubling?
Would you meet us at the very brink of our despair, our discouragement, our depression, our struggles, God?
And would we find love and hope and peace and freedom there?
Would we find a loving God who walks with his children?
Who provides for them in the desert?
Who sees them through to brighter days?
God, be with us.
It's in your name that we pray tonight. Amen.
All right, would you guys turn to the people around you?
Say hello, and then Brett will start the message.
Well, grace and peace.
It's good to be with you all.
So very good.
And yeah, I want to welcome you all into this space, and that includes those joining us online.
Don't forget to get your communion stuff for later in the service.
And yeah, just really, I'm grateful to be in this space with you.
And on a special night, a little potluck night.
It's always a really good time.
I hope you'll all join us after the service there.
And I also want to welcome anyone who's new into the space.
Thanks for having the courage to walk through those double doors.
It can be a lot coming into a new church community.
So we are in the season of the church calendar called the season of Epiphany.
And this time is all about kind of the delight of Christ.
It's like the revelation of Christ, right?
You've obviously had kind of the birth of Christ during Advent and Christmas.
And now it's kind of the beginning of like his ministry and just his light and beauty and love in the world.
And it's kind of an invitation also to us to like, how are we going to respond to that?
How are we going to reflect that light in our own kind of time?
So with that in mind, the title of my message this week is Growing in Belovedness.
And our scripture is Jeremiah chapter 1 verses 4 through 10.
And it says this,
I do not know how to speak.
I'm too young.
But the Lord said to me, do not say I am too young.
You must go to everyone I send you to and say whatever I command you.
Do not be afraid of them for I am with you and will rescue you declares the Lord.
Then the Lord reached out his hand and touched my mouth and said to me, I have put my words in your mouth.
See, today I appoint you over nations and kingdoms to uproot and tear down, to destroy and overthrow, to build and to plant.
So at one level, this story, it's like a very kind of specific narrative.
You know, it's like it's like rooted in history.
So this this isn't, you know, kind of very meta or mythological or something.
You know, this is talking about the prophet Jeremiah.
He was a real person.
He lived in like born somewhere around maybe 650 B.C. or so and lived through the Babylonian exile where the Jewish people were conquered by the Babylonians.
And he was part of the deportation there.
And he wrote the book of Lamentations, which some of you might be familiar with in the scriptures.
But you can kind of hear it in the name.
They're a book of lament.
So, you know, that's that's kind of his his story in this moment.
Like this is the beginning.
No, it's kind of that's why it's you can see it's in his book, Jeremiah, and it's chapter one verses four through ten.
Right. So you've got this kind of the very beginning of his life and calling.
However, if you're kind of familiar with the scriptures as a whole, you might have heard kind of in his story, certain like narrative kind of themes or tropes, you know, kind of a pattern.
That's it kind of occurs throughout the scriptures.
I think, for example, of the calling of the famous leader Moses.
Right. And the Lord kind of appears, speaks to him and calls him.
Right. Invites him to lead the children of Israel out of Egypt.
And what is what's Moses response to that?
Is he like, oh, great. I'm the man.
You know, no.
What does he say?
It's actually something very similar to what Jeremiah says here.
Not so much the age thing, but the I'm not much of a public speaker, you know, that like I can't do it.
I'm not really the leader type. Right.
And then what does God do?
Like, well, OK, I'll let your brother in law, Aaron, do some of the speaking.
But no, no.
Like I've called you.
You're you've got this.
Like I'm in you.
I'm with you.
I'll give you the words.
Then you've got like, for example, the story of the prophet Isaiah has very kind of similar theme.
He's there kind of deep in like a sort of meditative prayer when suddenly he has this vision of like the glory and beauty of God.
And he's overwhelmed.
He says, I'm I'm unclean.
I'm what he refers to specifically says I'm I have unclean lips, meaning kind of like speech.
And I live among a people of unclean lips.
And then this angelic figure kind of comes down in the vision with this hot coal and touches his lips.
Right now, there's a vision.
It's not literally like, you know, it's it's he just has this moment and he sees it in it.
And the angel says, see, your guilt is gone.
Your sins are forgiven.
And the voice of the Lord sounds out.
Who will go to the people?
Who will I send?
Who will go forth for us?
To which, you know, Isaiah is it's sort of a famous story in the scriptures says, you know, here am I send me, you know,
and you can kind of can you see some of the kind of themes happening there or take the calling of Mary, mother of Jesus.
Right. The angel of the Lord appears to her and his first words are, you're highly favored, Mary.
To which. She responds, not well, of course I am.
You know, but it says she was strangely or she was troubled at this strange greeting.
You know, so she's in other words, it's not this kind of confidence.
Yes, I shall be the mother of God.
And I was great, you know, but a kind of trepidation and a kind of like, OK.
And then and then a beautiful, though, kind of surrender to.
Yes, may it be unto me as you've said.
Or finally, there's the story of Christ himself.
We don't have a lot of detail from like his early life.
There's the story, I guess, of him in the temple teaching and such, you know, but we don't have a lot of like early Jesus stories.
We do have, though, outside of that kind of gap where birth and then right before his ministry kind of kicks off, he has his baptism.
Right. And you'll remember the spirit descends.
And then there's the voice of the one he called father that speaks out and says, this is my beloved son and whom I'm well pleased.
So can you kind of hear in that some of the themes like it's different, the details are a little different,
sometimes there's like an angelic figure, sometimes it's just the voice of God directly.
You know, it's different in its details, but there's a certain kind of pattern here.
And what I want to kind of contend tonight is that that pattern is not just for the high and mighty,
and it's not just for Mary, mother of God, or even only Christ himself.
But that actually that this is kind of our story, that God actually invites all of us into the same process.
So this is kind of a story I want to tell in three chapters.
Chapter one is beloved.
I think it's very important that we hear in this narrative that it that it begins, not ends.
Right. Not like, oh, you know, you did so good.
You are my beloved one. No, no.
Actually, the first word is this word of belovedness.
We are literally the one who is loved, the beloved.
As we read a few minutes ago, you hear it there in the calling of Jeremiah, verse five.
Before I formed you in the womb, I knew you.
Before you were born, I set you apart.
I mean, how many amazing things had Jeremiah done at that point?
Obviously, none.
This comes back to just our very essence as created in the very image of God.
You can see it in Mary's story with that language of you're highly favored.
And of course, there's Jesus. This is my beloved son in whom I'm well pleased.
Now, again, we're tempted to say like, well, see, but that's Jesus or that's Mary or that's, you know, that's for those folks.
But what I want you to notice, even in the case of Christ himself, right?
Again, this happens at the very beginning of his ministry, not the end.
So before he's done any miracles, before he's done almost anything extraordinary at all,
the Father speaks over him his belovedness.
Among modern Christian writers, I can't think of anyone who's written more beautifully about all these themes than Henry Nowen.
A few weeks back when I was listing books that I was like, oh, and these are good Christian books.
I'd highly suggest you read. Nowen's was one of them.
And in his book, Life of the Beloved, he puts it this way.
He says, first of all, you have to keep unmasking the world about you for what it is.
Manipulative, controlling, power hungry, and in the long run, destructive.
The world tells you many lies about who you are and you simply have to be realistic enough to remind yourself of this.
Every time you feel hurt, offended or rejected, you have to dare to say to yourself,
these feelings, strong as they may be, are not telling me the truth about myself.
The truth, even though I cannot feel it right now, is that I am the chosen child of God.
Precious in God's eyes, called the beloved from all eternity and held safe in an everlasting belief.
Can I get an amen to that? Like, Nowen, he's preaching there.
It's beautiful. And by the way, he was a gay man.
Closeted his whole life. He started to come out to just a few folks towards the very end.
He's, right, this isn't just abstract theology for him.
Like, this may be something you're struggling with.
No, no, this is his own story.
Struggling with this idea that he is beloved.
And I think that we've got to come back to this over and over again.
That really this is, you might call it, our great truth.
It's the very foundation of our life.
And anything to follow this, any word of correction or challenge or calling or whatever,
if it doesn't spring kind of from this root of, I am the beloved of God.
I am loved by God, treasured, chosen.
If it doesn't spring from that, then no matter what we do, inevitably, it gets weird.
I think often it turns into kind of earning.
You know, like, Yes, I will. You just watch me.
I'll be so faithful that surely then I'll be accepted.
Then I'll measure up. Then I'll be somebody.
And often we spend decades of our life kind of playing those games,
realizing that actually we have to start here.
That we're beloved by God.
It's not something earned, it's given.
Who am I?
Who are you?
You're the chosen child of God, as now it's said.
Before you were even born, God knew you.
God made you.
God sang you into being.
And you have life and breath right now
because the Spirit keeps on singing you into being.
And even if you never accomplish one thing
that the world would call some great success,
even if that never happens,
you simply are in your very being, in your existence,
your identity, the beloved.
And that's enough.
So we begin here.
Of course, easy to preach, easy to say,
easy to kind of nod along to, like, Yes, all right, point number one,
I'm the beloved.
Much harder to live into,
which leads us to the second chapter in the story of our life,
self-rejection.
If only it were so easy that we just had to hear this word of belovedness
one time and let it sink into the very core of our being.
And then from there on out, we just live our whole life
just grounded and rooted, just knowing.
No other word can kind of mess me up.
No, no, I know who I am.
But this is not what happens for us.
Not that easy.
Which is why, as I went through all those little narratives
with Isaiah and Jeremiah,
inevitably, in each of their cases, all but Christ, interestingly enough,
they almost all push back.
So God's like, I mean, take it with Jeremiah, right?
So verse five is like, Before you, I formed you in the womb, I knew you,
and all that.
And then what does he say?
Verse six, The last sovereign Lord, I said, I don't know how to speak.
I'm too young.
Or, of course, Mary, who's troubled, not inspired by the angel's words.
Or Isaiah with his, I'm undone.
I'm a sinner. I'm a wicked sinner.
And we have our own list.
It's mostly silent.
I think as adults, we mostly kind of keep it under wraps on the inside.
But it bleeds through in our actions, in our relentless perfectionism.
You don't have to raise your hand.
Any perfectionists in the room?
Just, I'm going to do it so good.
So good.
One day, I'm finally going to get it right.
And then I will be worthy.
It's this strange kind of compulsive thing.
Or our avoidance of anything we might fail at.
Sometimes it even manifests in a kind of intense criticism of others.
But rest assured, that person, anytime we get in that mode,
or we see it in others, we're like, Oh my gosh, they're so critical.
Trust me, they are 100 times more critical of themselves in their own minds.
It's like the hell.
You think it's hard being managed by them.
My God, imagine what it's like to be them.
It bleeds out.
I remember speaking with a man at our church.
It was the previous church, not the table.
Years back, 10 plus years ago.
And he was a good man.
Honestly, very outwardly successful.
Entrepreneur, started multiple businesses.
Winning at life.
And married, beautiful wife.
And great kids.
They'd gone through some tough times, kind of in their 20s,
but then kind of came out of it and were just thriving.
Doing great.
And he was really a pillar in the church community.
Served on teams.
Lead.
Just someone you counted on.
Incredible person.
But a little bit later, he went through some hard times in one of his businesses.
It just tanked.
And it hit him really hard.
His wife mentioned this to me.
Hey, could you check in on him?
So we talked once after church, and then we went out for coffee.
Or no, I went to his house.
It was a private conversation.
And I just wanted to check in, see how he was doing.
And honestly, I guess what I expected was probably some mild depression or something.
Or kind of like, just down.
Just hit me.
I hate to fail.
Struggling.
What I found was something entirely different.
This is what he said.
He said, Brett, you don't understand my role in life.
And then this is the thing he said.
This is the phrase that I for sure remember.
The rest I'm kind of paraphrasing.
But this I remember.
He said, my identity.
That's what he said.
My identity is to be a provider.
And if I cannot do that, I would rather end my life.
That's what he said.
And I remember sitting there just kind of stunned.
It was a moment where you could see how deeply this identity stuff goes for us.
Kind of all the way down into the roots of our psyches.
And it's there.
It's there kind of in the depths that we find that self-rejection kind of lurking.
We see it in, it can be kind of at times around age and giftedness.
That's a lot of the passages we looked at.
It's a lot of, I'm too young.
Or I suck at this.
I'm not good enough at that.
I could never be a leader.
It's a lot of that kind of thing.
But it's not restricted to that.
It can be around body image kind of stuff.
I'm too fat, too skinny, too ugly.
It can be around intelligence, education.
I'm stupid.
I'm an idiot.
I'm dumb.
And again, maybe we don't say it out loud, but it's relentlessly kind of in our heads.
It's there, this self-loathing, this rejection.
I'm a failure.
Who could ever want me?
I'm so unlovable.
If I died, no one would even care.
The world would not notice.
I'm such a screw-up.
I'm bad.
I'm worthless.
I'm a pile of crap.
What a wreck of a life.
I'm an embarrassment to my family and my friends.
See, here we come to the very roots of the problem.
I think we often zero in on the rejection of others.
You know, I got fired and I felt so rejected.
Or that partner left me and I felt so rejected.
But what I want to kind of focus in on is that the reason I struggle so much with the
rejection of others is often because I'm already struggling with self-rejection.
In essence, it feels like what they're saying about me aligns with the story I'm telling
myself about myself.
And it just cuts to the bone.
In other words, if I were really settled in my belovedness, then the opinions, the
acceptance, or lack thereof, the comparisons to others, wouldn't move me so much.
The reason I struggle with the rejection of others is because I'm already struggling
with self-rejection.
So how do we break out and move forward?
That brings us to our third chapter in the story, sending.
In each of the examples that we keep returning to, Isaiah and Mary and Jeremiah and so on,
there's not really this one moment where they come to see their belovedness and they're
like, yes!
And God speaks and they're like, yes and amen!
And then they go out and they just conquer the world.
And interestingly though, even though they don't do that, right, even though they always
as we looked at, they always kind of respond with a certain self-rejection and like, I
don't know, I'm too old or I'm too this or I'm too young.
It's interesting that God's response is never like, oh, okay, I didn't see that coming.
So yeah, well, let's hit the pause button.
Let's hit the pause button.
Let's give you a few years.
You'll get it together.
You'll get settled in your belovedness.
And then Gabriel will be back.
And hopefully you'll have a better answer this time.
Maybe you're a little more ready.
No, that's not really their response.
Instead, it's kind of like, that's okay.
In essence, the answer seems to be each of these people in the midst of their insecurities,
in the midst of their doubts, in the midst of their fears and self-rejection are in fact sent out.
In other words, the implication seems to be, I will figure out this belovedness thing as I go.
Sometimes I have to admit, I have this ridiculous sort of daydream fantasy.
I don't know what to call it, but like a ridiculous sort of dream or vision for my life.
And I don't even know if I could actually stand to do it, even if my life circumstances,
like family and marital status and role here at the table and all that,
like actually even aligned to do this.
It's like the most Brett kind of thing.
So this is kind of my fantasy.
So I hit the pause button on the table.
What exactly that means, I don't know, but it's just a daydream.
So I hit the pause button on the table, and I go off to a monastery for 20 years.
This is the Brett. This is right. This is where you're like, yeah, I'm Brett.
For those who know me well, this is classic Brett.
And I engage silence for hours and hours each day, and I become deeply settled in my belovedness.
And then, like Moses, returning from the mountaintop, I return to all of you.
And there I pastor you as you really deserve to be pastored by a saint, Saint Brett.
It's kind of nice to read.
Saint Brett.
See, some part of me believes this is what the world needs.
This is what you all need. This is what my family needs.
This is what you all deserve. Saint Brett.
That's the thing. You don't get Saint Brett, do you?
Some of you are like, no, no we don't.
You get Brett.
You get me. Me. As I am today.
Not even like as I'll be maybe in like 10 years.
I'm like, no, just Brett, today, here, now.
As I am.
With the good and all my crap and insecurities and all the unknowing and not really having a clue.
That's what you get.
But you can hear the self-rejection in that.
Can you relate to it? Not that you want to go off to monastery for 20 years, but can you relate to that self-rejection?
Can you see it in your own life where it happens?
Different for each person in a way, but it happens.
See, I believe Christ is saying to each and every one of you.
You are my beloved.
It's easy to believe that for others, like, yes, they are the beloved.
Or even we, yes, we collective, we are the beloved.
No, no, you, you are my beloved.
Behold, just like he told Jeremiah, behold, I'm placing my words in your mouth.
I'm placing my actions in your heart.
Go. You are being sent.
Today.
Not tomorrow, not in 20 years when you get it all together.
You're being sent today.
See, today I'm sending you to nations and kingdoms.
I'm sending you to your work and your community and your family.
Just like he told Jeremiah, there you will uproot and tear down all that is evil.
You will build and plant that which is good.
Go love the people.
And to that we say, but I am not ready.
And Christ says, I know.
I know.
But when will I learn of my belovedness?
How will I get all that worked out?
And Christ says, you will learn it on the journey.
All things work together for good.
Not necessarily that no disasters will befall you, but rather all things will teach you of your belovedness.
If only you had the ears to hear and the eyes to see.
The Spanish poet Antonio Machado put it this way.
Wanderer, your footsteps are the road and nothing more.
Wanderer, there is no road.
The road is made by walking.
By walking one makes the road.
And upon glancing behind, one sees the path that never will be trod again.
Wanderer, there is no road.
Only wakes upon the sea.
So in closing, you might ask, what do you want me to do?
Consider this a bit of Christian cognitive behavioral slash spiritual therapy.
When you notice thoughts of self-rejection arising, just repeat this mantra.
I'm loved.
I'm sent.
Repeat that any time you notice rejection creeping in.
May the Lord lead you into the knowledge of your belovedness.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
So, on the night that Jesus was betrayed, he had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held up a loaf of bread and he broke it.
He said, take it, eat.
This is my body.
It's broken for you.
And then he held up a cup of wine.
He said, this is my blood.
It's shed for you.
Whenever you eat this bread, whenever you drink this cup, remember me.
So, as we come forward tonight to participate in communion, as we take in his very body and life,
may it be a moment of just remembering again, receiving again the truth of our belovedness.
That greater love has no person in this than they give up their life for their friends.
And that's what Christ embodied for each and every one of us.
So, the way we'll participate in communion tonight, we'll just go row by row, starting here at the beginning.
We'll just form one line here in the middle.
And we practice what's called an open table.
Meaning, if you're here tonight and you want to participate, then you're free to do that,
regardless of your exact, you know, theology or denominational affiliation or whatever.
If you want to connect with Christ in this way, then you're welcome to come forward.
You should know the red is wine and the white is grape juice.
And then finally, you can just partake whenever and however you'd like.
Some folks like to come forward and kneel.
Others return to their seats to partake.
Some just take immediately, but no one will lead you through the exact moment of partaking.
You can do that on your own.
So, this is the table.
Not of the church, but of the Lord.
And it's made ready for those who love Him and for those who want to love Him more.
So, come.
You who have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who have not been here long.
You who've tried to follow and you who've failed.
Come.
Come, because it's the Lord Jesus Himself who invites you.
And it's His will that those who want to meet Him should meet Him here.
Come to the table.
Come.